Folks, I have
a simple philosophy.
The government should work for
everyone, not just the elite.
And that's why I helped
pass the farm bill,
because I care about farmers.
But I won't stop there.
I will work for everyone,
whether you are young,
whether you are old,
whether you are Asian
or Hispanic,
whether you are straight
or whether you are gay.
I will work for all of you.
And that's why I also
support marriage equality.
Folks don't choose to be gay,
anymore than I choose
to be straight.
Could you imagine
if someone told you
that you couldn't marry
the person that you loved?
I'm sorry, I think
gays are people too.
Gays are not different.
Gays, they're just like us.
They love, they fear,
they raise their children,
they strive for a better life.
But there are those
who believe that being gay
is an abomination.
That's absurd.
The homosexual community
is a valuable community
in this country.
They are doctors,
they are lawyers,
they are teachers,
they are me, and they are you.
And their contributions
are no less important
than any other group
in this fine nation of ours.
So, turn to that gay person
near you,
and see that they are
no different than you are.
Thank you.